Il y a 15 ans, lorsqu'il a commencé à creuser,
Vassil a eu la chance du débutant.
- On est ici devant la première tombe
qu'on a découverte, en 2001.
On a eu la chance de tomber tout de suite
sur une façade intacte.
Une façade qui date de l'ancien Empire,
l'âge d'or de l'Égypte antique,
et qui va le mener à d'autres tombeaux,
juste à côté.
Tous appartiennent à des prêtres,
des personnages qui ont passé leur existence
au service du pharaon.
Vassil, qui lit les hiéroglyphes
comme une bande dessinée,
a réussi à rentrer
dans l'intimité de ces personnages.
- Ici, nous avons un prêtre égyptien.
Il était au service d'un pharaon.
Et voilà, on est devant sa tombe,
devant la façade de sa tombe.
Donc c'est sa porte.
On rentre et la tombe est derrière.
Son nom veut dire :
"le roi Pepi est vivant".
Un peu comme si, aujourd'hui,
si je voulais être bien placé,
être un bon fonctionnaire de l'Etat français,
et que je m'appelais
"le président Hollande est vivant".
C'est exactement ça.
Du coup, je serais bien vu.
Lui, c'est exactement ça.
À côté, c'est sa femme.
Il l'aimait, bien sûr.
Il aime son épouse
donc elle s'appelle L'Aimée.
Mais on a un petit problème.
Entre les deux, on a une autre femme.
Et elle, elle s'appelle
"Celle qui rend le cœur vivant".
Ça, c'est le cœur.
Ça, c'est Celle qui rend le cœur vivant.
C'est tout un programme !
Et donc j'imagine,
bien sûr, c'est une hypothèse,
que c'est peut-être sa maîtresse.
Donc celle qui rend son cœur vivant,
bien entendu,
une plus jeune que son épouse, bien entendu,
c'est le rêve de tout le monde.
Et ce rêve, qu'il a dans sa vie terrestre,
il veut le transposer,
il veut que ça continue de l'autre monde.
Ces bas-reliefs qui décorent
la façade de la tombe sont inestimables.
Ils figurent parmi les plus anciennes
et les plus belles œuvres
découvertes sur le site de Saqqarah.
- Au fond, on a le puits.
Et c'est là, en bas, que se trouve la tombe.
Un puits de 9 m de profondeur
et un caveau en calcaire sans aucune décoration
qui était vide au moment de sa découverte.
Cette sépulture
a été pillée pendant l'Antiquité.
Toutes ces tombes sont protégées
par un plafond de métal
et par des trappes sécurisées
pour dissuader les voleurs.
Le pillage,
c'est aujourd'hui la hantise de Vassil.
Les objets que l'archéologue vient de découvrir
vont tous être mis en sécurité.
- Donne-moi le premier.
Vassil et Abdu doivent d'abord
les inventorier avec précision.
- C'est un couvercle.
La valeur marchande de tous ces objets
se chiffre en dizaines de milliers d'euros.
Ils seront bientôt à l'abri, dans les entrepôts
du ministère égyptien des Antiquités.
- On l'enregistre, on le photographie,
comme ça, il est protégé.
- L'objet a une identité.
- Exactement. Une identité.
Mais aussi, il est connu, déjà.
Une fois l'objet numéroté,
il doit pas disparaître
parce que ça y est, il existe.
Le désert de Saqqarah
regorge donc de trésors,
mais aussi de pilleurs
prêts à tout pour les récupérer.